hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um april 26th
stay we're almost through another one
oh what a who would have thought how do
i turn the volume down this
seems a little loud here it seems a
little loud oh
jesus you know i watched that poker
greenwich village i was telling you guys
that on saturday
and i can't get the summer wind was
blowing
in from across the sea
i cannot get that song out of my [ __ ]
head
it lingered there to touch your hair
just [ __ ] amazing lyrics um
anyway i am back here i'm going going
back back to i'm back in los angeles
um i had a great time on the acting gig
and uh i just got some great feedback
from the director
very excited very excited it was a
[ __ ] killer role
you know it was written amazing
and all i had to do was just say what
they wrote that's
that's how i do it okay
if you want if you want to be seen as a
good actor you
you just let everybody else do the heavy
lifting
let somebody else write some great [ __ ]
for you to say
and you will always look good that's
that's how i do it
um you know because i'm limited
all right go [ __ ] yourself i do what i
can i do what i can
so anyway uh as of this afternoon 3
30 p.m all freckles
oh billy red balls is fully vaccinated i
got my second vaccine
two weeks ago i'm all [ __ ] good so
i figured this fall tour might be
happening with the amount of people
getting vaccinated
and then the amount of people that got
covet already
so they have antibodies i think we can
you know maybe i can play at 200
seed maybe
uh you know people could be sitting next
to each other eating jalapeno poppers
like the old days ah that would be great
oh the summer wind
came blowing in into the funny bone
in springfield illinois or [ __ ] saint
louis
i don't care i just want to do
some stand-up comedy in a venue
that is indoors
and not have to scream over some [ __ ]
highway
traffic
so anyway um i'm almost
at the end of the second straight month
of being stone [ __ ] sober
um so whatever i gotta do something here
i'm gonna have a cigar next week i'm
gonna get all the way through april and
then i'm gonna sit down
and i'm gonna look through all the
[ __ ] cigars i have i'm gonna give
away a lot of them but i'm gonna have a
nice
[ __ ] stick i'm gonna [ __ ] down in a
[ __ ] lawn chair
i'm gonna put on a baseball game
on a transistor radio i'm gonna go total
[ __ ] old man
right shorts dark socks sock guarders
sitting in my driveway with a giant
[ __ ] umbrella over myself
while my kids at school so she won't see
me smoking
um so i can set an example
that's what you do that's you set an
example by pretending to be
somebody you're not
hello i am a sober person who tries not
to
to use curse words swearing
swearing that's how that's how white
people used to say it was swearing and
black people said cursing then somewhere
along the line
right when hip-hop [ __ ] crossed over
white people started saying cursing i
was swearing when i was a kid
you know and it was ranking on people
that was what [ __ ] making fun of
somebody
dude he got [ __ ] busted for swearing
and study
he was [ __ ] ranking on mark um and
the teacher came in
he didn't [ __ ] see him um
so anyway i had a great [ __ ] day
today
um i hung out with my kids my little man
is
walking does like four steps
um it's i don't know it's awesome and
it's also sad it's like oh i love my
little buddy when he would crawl across
the
floor you know because i get down on all
fours and i yell out his name
and he turns around he sees me gets this
big smile with his [ __ ]
two and a half teeth on the bottom and
he comes crawling over like super fast
like a [ __ ] komodo dragon except he's
adorable and won't eat you while you're
still alive like those [ __ ] things
um he already loves rough housing and
that type of stuff
he's he's hilarious and uh but now he's
like standing up but what's cool is
is now that he's almost a little person
once they start walking they become like
this little person
is he's now um
he's big enough where he can play with
his big sister and anybody out there
who's got a couple of kids knows that
amazing magical moment the first time
you see
your two kids playing with each other
it's the greatest
thing ever and i was worried that you
know
you know you always get worried like are
they gonna like each other or whatever
and he like
absolutely friggin idolizes her
like she comes in the room and he's
looking around just seeing you know
because she's got crazy kid energy
just like him and he just he's like i
that she whatever
this is that is like me and he just
gravitates towards her so
it's [ __ ] awesome man and uh you know
i get to ride bikes with my daughter
today
and um oh and then also
i uh you know i drive my old truck on
the weekends i like doing that [ __ ] so
i went over and i hung out with dean
delray
and uh we went over to this the big ford
dealership
out in the valley because i wanted to
look at the colors of the trucks just to
see all the different options and they
kind of got all these different colors
for the f-150
they got one it looks like a [ __ ]
root beer color
it was [ __ ] incredible they have a
shelby
f-150 you know
the whole thing with like the shelby
skunk stripe down the [ __ ] middle
just an insane insane truck and then
also
the last thing which i couldn't believe
i mean i'm a ford guy if you haven't
[ __ ] noticed i [ __ ] love forts
so um i took a picture of this thing i
took some video of it actually
and sent it to the guy who rebuilt the
engine on my truck they have um the mach
mustang it's in like fighter jet
gray and it has it's a six-speed stick
shift and it's got the white ball like
the old-school
hurst shifter on it it's just [ __ ]
insane [ __ ] insane
and i was with dean and dean was just
basically he was like dude if i had any
gigs on the books i'd
[ __ ] buy that right now
the thing was [ __ ] sick so
um anyway i got to see the velocity blue
on an f-150 and it looked really [ __ ]
cool if you have like if you don't get
the chrome if you get like the black
grill and everything
but um you know all of them were like
four doors i like the regular cab i
don't like the super
the way that they used to [ __ ] look
um when i was a kid
i like them uh looking like that so we
went over there
and then we went out and got like tacos
at this place uh
i think it says taco 1986 or something
[ __ ] amazing
amazing [ __ ] tacos out here that was
my afternoon i did that while my
daughter
was taking a nap and then i came back
my daughter was still sleeping
you know so i went into the garage back
my truck in and then
sat down and i played some drums and
then i got a text message that she was
awake
you know i opened the garage door we
rode bikes
and uh and then that's it and i'm gonna
hang out and have my
um i was gonna [ __ ] you say my once
a week [ __ ] milkshake because that's
all i do now
my one evil [ __ ] bad thing that i do
but i ate like [ __ ] when i was out on
the road though i'm not gonna lie to you
it's all about eating healthy when you
go on the road that first meal
has to be healthy for me or i just go
off the rails i literally [ __ ]
on the flight home the lady there goes
there's not gonna be any food on the
flight home
um and i was like oh [ __ ]
so i thought she meant even snacks
because they actually brought snacks
around so i went out and just loaded up
and i got like i usually get the small
can of pringles
potato chips but all they had was the
big one so i got that and then i was
like well i got to get a soda to go with
it
i said pop as they say in the midwest
and i went over and they actually had
[ __ ] root beer so there was that
and then i got a little charcuterie
[ __ ] thing
and i just sat there like a [ __ ]
lunatic
pulling my mask down every two seconds
just chowing down
and i bought some magazines
i bought this one uh the new yorker that
talked i
got you know i got through the first
third of the story
this poor woman from a certain part of
china where she lives
um i couldn't tell if it was this part
of china that has gone back and forth
between you know mongolia having control
of it china having control of it russia
having control of it
and there's some group of people over
there that are you know that live
there during all of this [ __ ] for
whatever reason they're not considered
chinese and now they're getting [ __ ]
with it's just that classic
like why can't people just [ __ ] leave
people alone
why can't they just let people be free
what the [ __ ] is wrong with human beings
what is that [ __ ] flaw
how can there be a god
if this is how human beings like the
[ __ ]
the sick and twisted ones that get to
the [ __ ] top
and just [ __ ] do this sick and
twisted [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] up there's got to be you know
what it is is
nice people
nice people don't kill other human
beings and psychos kill other human
beings that's how psychos get in control
the day nice people start killing
psychos i think you know
that's the day it starts to turn around
how do you get a nice person you know i
think psychos
that you know where everybody else tries
to live by the ten commandments
i think psychos live by like like three
commandments
that's like you know but you know uh
the fifth commandment does not exist
with those [ __ ] lunatics so
not saying i'm you know i haven't broken
some commandments here okay let's let's
be [ __ ] crazy here
uh but i'm just saying jesus christ
what kind of a [ __ ] the [ __ ] is that
on the windows goddamn
[ __ ] bugs they nervous to exist here
and there i am right here breaking the
fifth commandment with a [ __ ]
insect um all right
plowing ahead here um
so yeah i just don't know story i was
reading that and then i i got this
uh espn the magazine thing on hank aaron
which was that was amazing i read that
and then
i got this time magazine thing that was
talking about students
the young kids like they lost like a
year of school and interacting with each
other
and like what that's gonna do for him
and [ __ ] i didn't get around to that one
but um
i don't know i had a great time though
just
[ __ ] i haven't eaten that bad
like that like as far as just the amount
of random [ __ ] always had m
m's i mean this is like like when i was
in
junior high and i would go to lunch and
i didn't like what the lunch was for
that day and then i would just buy
a brownie the three cookies some chips
and i don't know what i remember one
time bringing all of that [ __ ] over and
this kid looks at me like dude you're
gonna get zits
um so
anyway um i forgot to tell you guys this
[ __ ] story right
um by the way i didn't i didn't did end
up going to a museum i went to this
native american museum
uh out where i was at and uh
you know it was just the art there was
just amazing
and you know the usual [ __ ] and then i
was just like yeah they were living like
this they're having a good time and then
white people came
you know and then you see the little
moccasins you know like
there were kids there too it's just like
i just don't
[ __ ] get how people can do that to
other people
look at this [ __ ] you know somebody went
out when i was telling me about
all right let me see if i can find this
uh native
americans i don't know what it was they
were basically they they got
you know relocated
to this patch of land that the white
people thought was [ __ ] uh
that it turned out to be it was sitting
on top of oil
and uh you know it was like the beverly
hillbillies
rebooted with native americans except
the beverly hillbillies when those you
know
poor white people found oil i mean
granted it's just a tv show
they [ __ ] they were allowed to keep
it well that's not what happened here
uh relocated oil
and we'll put in massacre and let's see
what this comes up here
okay in the 1920s a community conspired
to kill
oh sag murder reveal a conspiracy the
setting was the oh
sage i hope saying that right indian
nation in the 1920s when oil deposits
yeah this is it this is it so they just
started picking them off i think
members of the osage indian nation
became very wealthy in the 1920s after
oil deposits were found on their land
then local whites began targeting the
tribe
uh
yeah there's a new book on it oh [ __ ]
grand new terry gross host grand's new
book let's see history 1920s
g-r-a-n-n the guy wrote a book on it
um david graham
wow all right you want to hear me
i'll read a little bit of this here all
right so he's on fresh air
and all the conservatives all that
liberal [ __ ] it probably never even
happened
i bet the native americans that are the
ones actually attacked a lot people
um all right
okay right and then something
happens to her sister anna tell us about
that so her family becomes a prime
target of a conspiracy
and one day in 1921 her sister anna
brown disappears
and molly looks everywhere for her
searching along the prairie a week later
anna's body is found in a ravine
she's been shot in the back of the head
and it's the first hint that molly's
family has become a target of this
conspiracy
and that her tribe has become a target
of the conspiracy yeah they just started
picking them off
i mean can you [ __ ] imagine like
how [ __ ] greedy and sick
are you as a [ __ ] person
that you that you i don't know
like that you you you're buying into
this horseshit
that you're more of a person than this
other person so it doesn't even matter
if you walk up to some kid innocent kid
and shoot him in the back of the head
because you want this [ __ ] goop in
the ground
so you can do what get a [ __ ] hot tub
you know i guarantee that person
probably went to church every week
[ __ ] insane so uh yeah read up on
that
if you want i actually heard i think
martin scorsese and leonardo dicaprio
might be doing a movie on that i'm not
sure
i'm not sure i might have to bleep that
out i don't know if that's somebody told
me that i have no idea
um anywho um
yeah so anyway so i went to this museum
and i was sitting there and at one point
it had like this
this glass area you could just sort of
look out on the land
where some of these uh native americans
were
relocated to and this old woman was
sitting there there's these rocking
chairs and we're just sort of sitting
there
and i got up to leave and then she just
goes are those
eagles these birds were flying now i've
never seen an eagle as far as i know
i've never seen one
and i went out there and they were they
were [ __ ] eagles
i was like holy [ __ ] and i was trying to
squink on i can't see their white heads
though
and she goes that's because you know
they don't get the white
feathers until they get older she goes
those are either eagles or those are
giant hawks
really big hawks and i looked i said no
those are eagles because i
wanted them to be an eagle because i've
never seen one but i am 99.99
let's see i don't know let's see how
much of my money would i bet
well i don't can't lose my money kids
whatever i was really sure that they
were
um there was something about their wings
i took video of it i
zoomed in and just how the way they the
ends of their wings turn up like the way
they do like on like those jets how they
got that thing on the end of the wing
now
um whatever i think i finally saw a
[ __ ] eagle and i was pretty goddamn
excited about that
but here's a story that i wanted to tell
you i forgot to tell you this
when i was on the plane ride out
all right um i got a first class ticket
because that's how i fly okay i spent 20
years in the back of the plane i ain't
going back
but i can tell you right now it's not a
bad time to fly in the back of the plane
i felt stupid
i sat up in first class first class
first class was packed
and then in the back there was like
nobody so those people could like
stretch out and [ __ ] and also not have
to worry about somebody [ __ ]
breathing on you
you know with the [ __ ] next ebola or
some [ __ ] so i got a kick out of that
so anyway i'm sitting there and on the
flight out
this [ __ ] douche
this [ __ ]
douche in the [ __ ]
first class front row not talking about
myself not saying i'm not a douche
either
but you know i was a quiet douche this
douche was a loud douche
an unmistakable douche the the flight
attendant
the lady there the lady stewart is there
she [ __ ] goes um we might all the the
douche started
bitching about the [ __ ] internet
before we even got going
and she goes we well we might have a
problem i'm not really sure
she said something about how the
customer service
something about the customer service and
the guy goes yeah that's so you won't
have bad
ratings and he started bitching and he
started bitching about how they made the
seats more uncomfortable
and he's [ __ ] talking to her like
she's the one that puts the seats in the
[ __ ] plane
right now i got no problem if some
stewardess is [ __ ] sitting there
going like you know
sir can you [ __ ] stick the thing in
the [ __ ] so we can get going
if you're gonna be like i don't have a
problem at that point being like hey
lady i'm doing the best i can here hey
buddy
relax okay you're cramming us in here
like sardines i'm trying to do the best
i can here
all right i don't have a problem with
that but when you start
bitching about literally the plane like
she has that that that type of stuff
there i mean it's [ __ ] ridiculous so
this guy goes uh you know you made the
seats more uncomfortable blah blah blah
blah
and i so wanted to be like hey fatso
what about the fact that you've probably
gained three and a half to
seven and a half pounds every year since
you graduated
you're at least 40 pounds over [ __ ]
weight maybe if you hit a [ __ ]
salad every once in a while the seats
wouldn't seem so uncomfortable
they don't feel uncomfortable to me i've
been flying [ __ ] this airline forever
why didn't i say that there's got to be
a nice way to say it without getting
kicked off the plane
excuse me sir i couldn't help notice but
you're you seem to be
obese okay
i'm not saying you're going to be on my
600 pound life but just being 30 pounds
overweight is is is
you know they can write you up for being
obese even at your height and
you look like you're at least 50 60
pounds overweight
okay so i mean what are they supposed to
wheel on here
a [ __ ] double wide lazy boy for your
fat ass
it's [ __ ] dude it's [ __ ]
ridiculous now people always say that i
come down on fat people
i i do i come down on them because
they're chowing down and then they turn
around they start bitching at people
and they they don't they don't address
the problem you know what i mean
it's like i'm a bald orange [ __ ] okay
my head is gonna get colder faster
than someone that has a nice thick
luscious mane of [ __ ] hair
right if i'm gonna [ __ ] sit there
and and and you know i'm sitting on the
plane and everybody else with a full
head of hair feels fine
am i gonna start bitching that it's a
little chilly in there
if i feel chilly i [ __ ] look around
i'm like oh all right when nobody else
is [ __ ] complaining
i put my hat on
i don't start bitching about the [ __ ]
vent you know
but bald people are not considered
uh handicapped or whatever the f
whatever these fatsos are [ __ ]
angling towards
you know i don't know
i just couldn't [ __ ] look at bitching
about the chin the lady had to literally
sit there it's this
fat slacked [ __ ] burger eating jerk
off it's talking about
uncomfortable [ __ ] seed it's like you
think the seats on how do you think the
seat feels
trying to hold your [ __ ] lard ass up
i don't know but i know you're not
supposed to say that you're supposed to
call these people heroes
and say that they're beautiful as they
eat their way into a diabetic coma
i guess that's the way you do it i mean
i don't know
it's [ __ ] strange to make so
i mean if you can have kick a ginger
date i can't make fun of fatties i just
don't understand
i should actually like fat people so in
kick and ginger day they're easy to
outrun
maybe that's what it is so what else can
i [ __ ] about to get people going
uh oh yeah i was i went down to the
supermarket today
you know because i gotta [ __ ] make up
for all the uh
horrific way i just ate over the last
couple of days
on that amazing super fun [ __ ] acting
gig
um so i get outright i'm driving down
the street
and the person in front of me is driving
like super [ __ ] slow or whatever and
there's this
[ __ ] guy i couldn't get mad at him he
was on a bicycle
right but he was at least over on the
side of the road so he was trying to
share the road right
as opposed to those [ __ ] [ __ ]
that run like ride like two side by side
out in the road with their whole share
the road
thing like you know you have to [ __ ]
you know
acknowledge me and [ __ ] be safe
around me and all that and then you
watch him
blow through red lights and stop signs
even though they're legally required
to follow the same rules of the road
they all [ __ ] fly through they don't
put their feet down with their little
dancing slippers that they have clicked
in like they're in some [ __ ] time
trial right
so anyway this guy's driving down the
street and what's [ __ ] hilarious to
me
is from the waist down he looks like a
drunk driver who lost his license he's
trying to get to work he's got on jeans
regular sneakers and he's riding on the
side of the road but up top
he's got the [ __ ] yellow lance
armstrong
jersey like he's the leader in the
[ __ ] race so that just cracked me up
so i was actually muttering to myself
going you know i'd get mad at this guy
but he's obviously leading this [ __ ]
race here of drunk drivers
convicted drunk drivers so i don't want
to get mad at him
but um he [ __ ] blew through two red
lights
in the time i was behind it was
hilarious just [ __ ] hilarious
um it's not hilarious but when they get
hit then they act like it's some [ __ ]
tragedy and it's just like
you know i saw a thing on [ __ ]
instagram this guy in a motorcycle now i
love [ __ ] motorcycles and that type
of [ __ ] but if you're gonna do [ __ ]
wheelies
in traffic this [ __ ] guy is doing
this wheelie right
[ __ ] it down and this person goes to
make a [ __ ] u-turn
and this guy doesn't see him because
he's doing a [ __ ] wheelie
and fortunately full speed or whatever
like doing like i swear to god like 50
miles an hour
slammed into the passenger rear side
door and everybody's like oh my god that
person doing the u-turn what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
blah blah blah blah a few people said
they were both at fault but nobody
addressed the fact that if that dude
with that [ __ ] bike
had hit the driver's side door
perpendicular like that i mean i would
think you would do
could kill somebody doing that right i
don't know
i kind of feel like bike riders
motorcycle riders and
fat people and feminists
never think they're in the wrong
all right sorry every once in a while
you just gotta say some dumb [ __ ] to
make sure the emails keep coming in that
ought to get them going
you know and what's funny is
guys who ride bikes shave their legs
but women who are feminists do not it's
weird
it's just a [ __ ] weird thing and fat
people would shave their legs but they
can't get to it
they say oh my god you could sell one
for 19.99 you know that [ __ ] you know
that helps like
you know those big people [ __ ] wash
their backs you know
i'm miming it right now it's like it's
like a [ __ ] loofah
with with a [ __ ] uh flagpole attached
to it right it's
a tent stick right you do that
you get one of those for uh with a
shaving blade on the end of it
you know 1999.
oh my god my legs have not looked this
smooth in years
um all right i think that's enough
[ __ ] ignorance
just every once a while you got to prime
the pump people you know what i mean
um all right let's let's read uh
let's read some of the advertising did i
forget to put it on my thing here
oh jesus
oh i see what happened i see exactly
what happened
what happened is i [ __ ] up oh look who
it is everybody it's butcherbox
you know finding affordable quality
meats
is not easy luckily
today you know a woman over 50 could say
the exact same thing a divorced woman
over 50 sorry
luckily today's sponsor butcherbox
believes everyone deserves high quality
humanely sourced meat no added
antibiotics
or hormones ever each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat enough
for 24 individual meals you know what's
great about two
eating land animals at this point is
they're not in the ocean
inhaling plastic because evidently women
are having babies now
and the babies have a little bit of
plastic already in their system because
the mom
was eating fish trying to be healthy
it's unfucking real unfucking real um
each box has 911 pounds of meat enough
for 24 individual meals packed fresh and
shipped
frozen and vacuum sealed so it stays
that way
you know what somebody right now is
probably arguing well the animals on
land
and neither one of us is going to get to
the point here is that the people up top
got to stop putting their [ __ ] in the
plastic bottles we got to eliminate
plastic man
oh [ __ ] am i on an awards show sorry uh
butcher box couldn't be easier just sign
up select your box and they ship it
right to your door every month
and when you sign up now you get a free
essentials bundle in your first box
three pounds of chicken breast two
pounds of pork chops
and two pounds of ground beef all for
free in your first box
who does not love free meat butcher box
is the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy humanely raised meat
when with butcher box you get the
highest quality meat around
around for just six dollars a meal
and they even have free nationwide
except for alaska and hawaii
they ship for free nationwide uh for a
limited time butcher box is offering new
members a free essentials
bundle in their first box that's three
pounds of chicken breast two pounds of
pork chop
and two pounds of ground beef all for
[ __ ]
free in your first box and and on top of
that
there's anybody homeless listening to
this man this is what you got to do
right here get free [ __ ] meat
you know and on top of all that for all
the monday morning podcast listeners
butcher boxes offering ten dollars off
of your first box just go to
butcherbox.com for ten dollars off your
first box plus a free
essentials bundle that's butcherbox.com
for 10
off your first box and a free essentials
bundle speaking of plastic bottles i'm
drinking a bottled water here
but it's in a in an aluminum can liquid
death
yummy i prefer the aluminum aftertaste
as opposed to plastic oh look who it
me is throw it in the [ __ ] ocean
me undies me undies then you're feeling
a [ __ ] motion
in your stomach cause the bottle came
back
you're taking this [ __ ] that doesn't
look like crap
because it's your bottled water coming
back to haunt your ass
and [ __ ] all over your soft
underwears
[ __ ] me undies all right me undies
summers is
summers summer is coming oh by the way
you know you guys always get on me for
saying any ways
when i was in the supermarket today
somebody said to this guy he goes
he said back in the days not back in the
day
back in the days the days all right my
undies summer is coming
and for so many of us it's the season of
discomfort it's hot out
and you could sit around in just your
underwear oh if you could sit around
just your underwear you would uh
another another great example of
why living in the middle of nowhere is
great because you can sit in your
underwear
you know or if you've got some proper
tire you can walk around [ __ ] butt
ass naked
uh me undies wants to make this the
summer of comfort
and they want you to know that if you
want to sit around
in your underwear that's absolutely
allowed get comfortable and express
yourself this summer with
undies in classic and bold colors and
fun and adventurous prints
rushing home to change into something
more comfortable
is the a thing of the past you know
exactly what i'm talking about
stay comfy and be undies all day get
undies socks
uh braillets and more i don't want that
bralettes sorry and more choose from i
tell you i keep eating the way i'm
eating i'm gonna need a [ __ ] relative
choose from endless styles in sizes
extra small to 4xl with their
sustainably soft
micro model and ultra light breathe
fabrics me
undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first time purchasers
you get 15 percent off and free shipping
myani's also has their problem free
philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason
they'll refund or exchange it no caveats
no questions
to get your 15 off your first order
and free shipping go to meundies.com
that's meundies m m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
me on dies dot com slash
burr for 15 off your first order and
free shipping
baby all right that's it okay
i sound like that [ __ ] air horn that
they always have
um [ __ ] bruins lost again we lost to
the sabers we lost to the penguins
but um whatever i feel good about the
team
i feel good about the team um
all right let's let's do some of the
reads here for the week let's see how
far into this [ __ ] [ __ ] am i
34 minutes of just absolute
[ __ ] ignorance oh by the way i didn't
know max verstappen won the sex
sex the second uh formula one
race of the season so
uh uh lewis hamilton won the first one
verstappen was in second
and then verstappen won the second one
and lewis hamilton was in second
so lewis hamilton's up by one or two
points you know i swear to god i swear
to god if verstappen
had just passed him and just stayed at
canter
over it would have been a legal pass he
would have won both [ __ ] races
all right so i'm already worried that
that's all he need i just want to see
somebody else
i don't give a [ __ ] if lewis wins it i
just want to see competition so it looks
like it's going to happen this year
uh
so i'm i'm in i'm in so i'm watching the
formula one
and i'm watching the [ __ ] moto gp
and they both have races next weekend so
i'm very excited about that
um i think that's it right is that all i
wanted to talk about yeah i think it is
oh the oscars are tonight too by the way
um which seemed really cool that they're
doing them at the uh
union station downtown um
nia showed me the opening with regina
king
um coming walking in this whole
like tracking shot whatever the [ __ ] you
call it look cool as hell though
so we shall see we shall see what
happens there all right hoa
[ __ ] continued oh home
organization association or something
like that this is when like people in a
neighborhood
want to pretend that they live in a
gated community but they don't they just
want to control
who moves in and who does once again
it's just one of those things that
starts off it's a great idea
hey we have a nice [ __ ] neighborhood
here you know
all it takes is one [ __ ] jerk-off to
come in knock a house down and then make
build something that looks like a white
castle that happened to a buddy of mine
it literally a guy built you know
literally built a house that looked like
a [ __ ] white castle
thinking his house looked like a castle
it doesn't it looks like i can go in
there
and order those delicious tiny little
burgers oh my god
i haven't eaten a white castle in
forever um
anyway hoa
[ __ ] continue but then what ends up
happening is it's just this great way
to uh what's gonna happen is
you know you start the hoa is most
people are gonna
sort of participate and what's gonna
happen is these psycho control freaks
once again
will rise to the top and then they will
just start
unleashing the psycho within
and this is the vehicle all right hoa
[ __ ] continued
dear billy buckets of frankincense
and burr i don't know what frankincense
is
um i know it's been a few weeks since
you've talked about the horrors of
neighborhoods with an
hoa so i figured i would rekindle the
fire a bit i love it last june i bought
a house that is in a neighborhood with
an
hoa uh and while i knew beforehand that
hoas are usually a [ __ ] scam i really
had no choice as most of neighborhoods
in my area have them uh yeah
plus you know houses are so [ __ ]
expensive now it's almost like if you
can afford one
people just gonna grab it you know all
right oh well
well the house i bought had these
boulders on the corner of the driveway
in the street
probably to prevent people from driving
on the grass
fast forward a few months i get an email
from the hoa
president christina whom i always refer
to
in email replies as christine
in hopes to piss her the [ __ ] off oh
dude that's [ __ ] hilarious
anyways she emails me telling me i need
to remove the
rocks or i'll be fine twenty dollars a
day after the 10th day if i do not
remove them
so i go into google maps and i look at
the street view from two years prior
and i see the boulder sitting there
which means she just now decided to
enforce this rule
that causes no harm to [ __ ] anyone
like what if you don't [ __ ] what
jurisdiction do they have
uh no i can't afford to do it
she goes anyway he goes i removed the
rocks and then emailed her back stating
so
you should have put them in her yard
no you know what you do just save one of
them
save one of them right
and then a few years later like a psycho
irishman that never forgets you throw it
through her [ __ ] bay window
no don't do that don't do that i removed
the rocks and then emailed her back
stating so
and how they were in the two-year-old
street view pictures
and also asked her how one gets elected
hoa
president because i was interested in
the job
not surprisingly she replied with the
short thank you for removing the rocks
without acknowledging any part of the
email yeah
that's right dude you [ __ ] go after
her
to top it off the [ __ ] raised hoa dues
by 50 a year for 2021
which can only be stopped if there is an
80 percent support against
the rate raise it's honestly hilarious
to me how much of a power trip christine
stonework is on telling other middle
class homeowners what to do
[ __ ] hoas have a good weekend and go
[ __ ] yourself oh dude yeah
yeah oh yeah dude
that is like that would [ __ ]
eat me up inside so what you your only
thing that you can do
is just keep doing more of that
christine [ __ ] to her
that's the only thing that you can do
and then run and then what you have to
do
is just be a [ __ ] salt of the earth
guy for everybody else in that
neighborhood
run for [ __ ] president and run on the
platform
and if elected i will not break your
balls
about [ __ ] ticky tack horseshit
in your [ __ ] yard
i will not allow crazy people to move in
this neighborhood
but i will not tell you how tall your
[ __ ] shed can
or can't be who the [ __ ] isn't gonna go
with that
that's what you do all right
flat earther wanted to reach out oh i
love it
i love it you know here we go here we go
let's get into this
come on convince me hey billy beta boy
i'm a beta boy now okay and you're the
alpha
okay i see you're constantly discussing
the flat earth phenomenon
i'm not constantly discussing it you are
i'm just making fun of it fat people
think i'm
constantly talking about them or i have
been lately
um can i ask you a question do you think
fat people are around do you think
they're flat too
ah sorry it was too easy um and i wanted
to reach out for the record i am not
a scientist or mathlete yeah i could you
know you didn't need for the record i
could have [ __ ] told you that
i have however read tons of literature
and non-fiction books about the
discussion
a non-fiction book was written about
this what for the [ __ ]
1200s i am reaching out to see you
to see if you are actually interested in
hearing from a genuine
critical thinker on the topic i have a
powerpoint that has been
in the works for some time and would be
doing a video about it
uh to start up no i'm not reading this
i'm not i'm not gonna [ __ ] read your
powerpoint [ __ ] discussion
what i want you to i just want you
[ __ ] flat earthers to tell me
what why would they tell you it's round
when it's flat
what is the advantage i get i get a lot
of conspiracy
i get people when they say i'm worried
about the vaccine
what if this is what they're using for
population control
i i that makes that paranoid thought
100 percent makes [ __ ] sense
considering what governments have done
to forget about other people their own
[ __ ] people
what what what this government has done
to people who aren't [ __ ] white i i
100 get that paranoia
okay because i see the [ __ ]
the reason that they're doing it and the
advantage of of them
doing that taking out all of these
[ __ ] people
so they can live these people all
[ __ ] die and then this global warming
[ __ ] slows down there's more room for
them more property and all that [ __ ]
i totally get that [ __ ] but i just don't
get like
if it was flat
right why would you tell me it's [ __ ]
round
because the reality is i don't care
as long as gravity still works and i
don't
float away from the [ __ ] planet i
don't give a [ __ ]
but this [ __ ] crap here
where people are trying to say that
there is a [ __ ]
ice wall like somebody
would have seen it and taken video of it
why is there no video of the [ __ ] ice
wall
why isn't there anything out there where
there's people standing looking over
going look at this if i take a step here
i'm going to fall all the way down off
the earth
right just show me that
i'm not reading a bunch of [ __ ] books
but if you want to read books on this
this is to start off with
the moon is within the earth's
atmosphere
even if we went to the moon it's still
not in outer space oh my god
sir could you get a pilot's license and
then please tell me that you still
believe this [ __ ]
um flat earth as a concept is not old
is that old yeah no
my whole life everybody thought it was
[ __ ] round until the internet came
around
uh it is actually new
oh you're saying back in the day columba
okay the book below basically discusses
how it was an invention to discredit
evolutionary critics
from the time of the greeks onward
anyone was aware of the shape everyone
was aware of the shape of the earth and
yes the
the meme that columbus was the only one
who thought the earth was round is
entirely inaccurate
uh yeah i would believe that i believe
that yeah i believe that there was
plenty of smart people that [ __ ]
figured that out
mathematically
oh my god are you gonna tell me now that
the sun goes around the [ __ ] earth
um okay i
i don't i don't know what to tell you
here buddy okay uh
i'm sure you're aware of the origins of
nasa
being that america took in war criminals
an organization we should be skeptical
of at the very least
yeah absolutely i agree with that but
like the thing about it is
is then every single [ __ ]
country our allies our enemies
every [ __ ] leader all of them all the
scientists all got on the same page
for this [ __ ] lie they can't get on
the same page about anything
we can't even get on the same page about
what to do or what not to do
with this [ __ ] virus but you're
telling me
all of these world leaders who
constantly fight each other
constantly make up [ __ ] constantly steal
from each other constantly try to wipe
each other out
so the one place where they all agree to
lie about is that the world's around
that's what the [ __ ] you're telling me
um like i said before i am not in
and not intelligent in a standard sense
well neither am i
okay but i'm smart enough to listen to
other i don't know whatever
i've been told i'm more wise than smart
i'm not a christian i am college
educated currently serving
in the california army national guard
well that's great have somebody take you
up in a [ __ ] plane
uh thanks and go [ __ ] yourself with
knowledge yeah buddy i'm i'm not wasting
my time with that i am not wasting
my [ __ ] time with that until somebody
can
one okay look here's the deal i will
read that [ __ ] if you can tell me
what the advantage of is telling a
meathead like me
that it is [ __ ] round when it's
actually flat
actually [ __ ] all of that
there is video about everything
everybody has a [ __ ] camera with them
right now
send me video of somebody standing on
the [ __ ] ice wall
okay at the edge of the [ __ ]
all of these [ __ ] people that have
pilot's licenses
and have boats and all of this [ __ ]
somehow they've never gone out and seen
it
and posted it on their [ __ ] youtube
page like hey man
i don't want to freak people out but
like i was sailing around the world and
got a little lost and i ran into a
[ __ ] wall
right in the middle of the ocean and
then i climbed up on it i mean what the
[ __ ]
all right anyway
not to mention i flew around the world
one time in a plane
so the pilots must have been in on it
right
like just do a subtle
i flew from lot i flew from la to
australia
back to new zealand up to singapore
hong kong mumbai then dubai
then new york city and then to la
okay i did that
and if you're gonna sit there and tell
me that this guy was doing all these
twisties and turnies and all of that
type of [ __ ]
that essentially
that every i i can't get into it
i mean dude there's a [ __ ] reason why
when they fly to europe they fly
north first before they head over the
[ __ ] ocean
it's because it's round and up top there
it's a shorter distance and they save
money on fuel
or or is the map that i'm watching on
the plane
also lying to me which would mean all of
these [ __ ] people know that it's
really [ __ ] flat and for whatever
reason
they're all lying to people like me and
for what
i actually think you're just doing this
just to [ __ ] with me just to watch me
get worked up
i will go along with a lot of [ __ ]
conspiracy theory but i i just can't
with that one i can't
i can't do it all right censorship uh
dear billy bubble boy i work for a small
magazine and in the last few years
the amount of censorship i've seen is
incredible
yeah i don't doubt that and i'm an older
lady and i've been writing for lifestyle
and arts for 40 years
every day now i see some form of
silencing
or ostracizing over opinions yeah and i
bet it's coming from the left
benign ones too the and yeah from the
left and from
corporate lawyers who are trying to
preemptively anticipate
how these lefties are gonna get [ __ ]
these severe lefties are going to get
offended
uh the diversity of ideas is almost dead
our pitch meetings used to have really
independent ideas
i assume there would be a reversal but
instead it's it has become more vigilant
it's common it's coming it's adjusted
it'll just back and then they'll be in
the middle again i'm not speaking about
controversial topics for example a piece
on a newly discovered art form
art from a particular part of the world
was pitched to the editors
but because the region of the world the
art came from
is associated with taboo opinions
it could inadvertently upset a reader
yeah this is because of people on the
left
the extreme people on the left this is
what they did to critical thinking
free ideas and all of that and they
think
that they are liberal and they're not
they are [ __ ] they're dictators um it
reminds me of a society the society my
father grew up in
in eastern europe all opinions published
and taught in schools were subjected to
a collective
idea always disguised as what's good for
the people
do you see a reversal in this would
appreciate your insight
yes i do and what it's going to take is
people
going out of your way to say exactly
what the [ __ ] you're thinking
um i've been trying to do that with my
stand-up act
just to just
just i really have to work on
pushing out because there was like a
three-year period where i
kind of gave into that oh i don't say
that uh maybe some of you if i say that
am i going to get in trouble and i
started
like you know alligator arming some [ __ ]
and then last summer i did the chappelle
um
uh retreat there out in ohio and there
were no phones or anything and i was
like holy [ __ ] this is the way it used
to be
and i could say whatever i wanted and i
was and i realized
that because of these [ __ ] lefty
[ __ ]
i had been censoring myself on stage
and i should not have done that and
um
so i think there needs to be an
awakening
because i think a lot of people are
doing what what
you're the place you where you work at
are actually doing it themselves
um a lot of advice i get from my reps is
don't do that
it's not worth it don't you know
uh don't say this don't do a a project
about this
don't stick up for this comic that's
getting [ __ ] on it's not worth
it it's not worth it it's not worth it
it's not right i've pretty much ignored
that
for the most part those ones when people
are getting canceled there's that thing
where
it's like you want to support but then
you also don't want to keep it going and
you're kind of hoping it's one of those
three-day things and then nobody gives a
[ __ ] and they've moved on to something
else it's really a [ __ ]
shameful period um
um much like the red scare
and and just when when this all is said
and done and people look back on it the
amount of like really decent
people who just didn't do anything wrong
who had their careers taken from them
um you know it's just [ __ ]
i don't know it's just human beings
we're awful um
okay here we go why i don't care about
being
obese all right dear bill
i don't listen to your podcast a lot
mostly just youtube clips
and your specials on netflix uh while on
youtube the other day i came across bill
maher's opinion on fat shaming
which led to this rabbit hole of
different celebrities sharing their
opinion on obesity
then i remembered you are you calling me
a celebrity thank you
uh on your special talking about how
plus-sized models
wanted to be treated as beautiful or
fatties as you call them
i'm morbidly obese and i agree these
people are not beautiful and i doubt the
vast majority of the general populace
think that they are beautiful unless you
have a bbw
kink i don't know what that is having
said that
i being a fatty am an impervious to fat
shaming
i know i am ugly okay we share that
i know i'm ugly too all right and fat
and no one
would want to touch me the thing is i
don't care
okay well you care on some level because
you're writing me
uh this is not to say that i allow being
fat to overly interfere in
other people's lives i normally buy a
business class seat
because they are bigger and i won't make
the person next to me feel squished
if i can't fit in the car with my
friends i'll hire a cab or an
uber which takes me along with them to
wherever we want to go
i know being fat is curable the thing is
i don't want to cure it
you just that's [ __ ]
this guy's like the punk rock fat guy um
that was like this guy i know he's been
just boozing his face off
forever and he's never tried to quit
there's something i don't know
there's something i envy about that um
anyway and if someone tries to shame me
rather than persuade me to cure it it
just irritates me
at one point i literally recreated
the 100 dollar to [ __ ] off me
i don't know what that is let me explain
why i don't care or why other fat people
might not for me
food is an addiction not only fast food
like mcdonald's or burger king
even gourmet food like kerala
lobster and what that is or shikorakara
this addiction combined with the high
stress environment of the education
system
here leads to a lot of stress eating
eating helps me cope with the pressure
associated with
exams here eating also yeah but dude you
can
cigar smoking help me keep take the edge
off the day and drinking did all of that
you can pick you can choose something
different dude don't kill yourself
you're gonna kill yourself
um eating also is both a you know what
it is
i try i kind of figured out why i
abused alcohol edibles cigars
and [ __ ] like that i figured out i was
like i figured out because i wasn't
happy
with myself and i had all this pain from
[ __ ] years and years and years ago
that i never dealt with
and when i would start to feel these
feelings rather than allowing myself to
feel them
figure out what they were talk to them
about somebody
cry it out of you whatever you had to do
i would just
booze my face off and yell
and get in arguments with complete
strangers about a [ __ ] minnesota
twins verse red sox game 40 years or
something [ __ ] stupid like that
so you know i don't know you're not
asking for advice so i won't give you
any but i i hope that
you know at some point you know
you turn it around all right eating also
is both a literal and figurative escape
for me eating can be
figurative escape because it allows me
to cope as said earlier literally i'm
hoping i get a heart attack and no one
finds me till it's too late
and i figure at this point you're asking
yourself well why don't you use a razor
blade or a noose
to be completely honest i'm a shitty
coward
i'm both scared of death and kind of
welcome it dude i swear to you have no
idea how
how alike you are with me
uh i'm too scared to plug in the toaster
and drop in the bath yet when my heart
gives out i'm not gonna cry out for help
i'm just gonna lay on the floor close my
eyes and be at peace
wow dude you're kind of scaring me here
because i don't want you to do any of
this [ __ ] to you but i'm also it's
freaking me out how much i relate to
everything you just wrote
until then i'm gonna study for my law
exam and work a few odd jobs and just
because
just because i am scared what till then
i'm gonna study for my law exam and work
a few odd jobs just because i'm scared
all this is not to say that your jokes
are not good
they're [ __ ] awesome honestly i kind
of don't understand why people would get
offended
at a joke unless it was really egregious
you and a few other people online are
what's
making my life slightly less bearable uh
keep making the same jokes
you always make and never give a [ __ ]
about what other people think best
wishes
yeah dude you gotta you gotta [ __ ]
figure out why you're doing that to
yourself
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that you
just wrote there
which i think a lot of people relate to
where
you know i don't kill myself because i'm
too afraid to do it but like you know
death does seem like a [ __ ] like
ah it's over you know what i mean
i totally 100 percent
um relate to that
but uh i don't know
hey man you like to eat right why don't
you eat some mushrooms maybe you'll have
the same [ __ ] results that i did
which is i i realized how much
loneliness
sadness and depression was in me for so
long
and i actually figured out where it came
from
and now i'm in therapy and i'm trying to
figure that out
and because of that since the end of
february
i haven't done any damage to myself
um other than [ __ ] you know
some milkshakes or whatever but [ __ ]
i've tried to like
figure out why it is i was doing to
myself
what i was doing um which is i think you
know whatever it is
boozing over eating whatever the [ __ ] it
is
if you can figure out the why
then you can try to fix
that and then i think [ __ ] it's easier
to kind of like level stuff out
i think but you're also talking about
somebody who's only for two months
has i'm new to this [ __ ] so anyway i
hope you turn around if you want to turn
it around but
um all right that's it okay you seem
like a cool guy all right girlfriend
thinks i'm gay
dear old billy bonkers i have a
situation that is kind of hilarious and
kind of [ __ ] up so i thought this
might be the perfect place for a little
advice
insert 30 seconds of silence while you
fumble to get your theme song
oh you're right let me see here
is this it right here it's time for
advice hey
somebody else okay here we go um
let's see here oh wait now does it go
into the next [ __ ] thing here
no it doesn't all right cool all right
um
my girlfriend i my girlfriend and i have
been together for about
three and a half years and i truly am in
love with this girl
she checks all of the boxes and then so
and then some super smart beautiful
funny amazing family and she loves me
i absolutely see a future with this girl
i'm 25 she's 23.
so i know where so i know we're young
but i've been told i'm very mature for
my age and she's
getting there um no there's nothing
wrong with getting married that young
then you can have kids when you're young
and [ __ ] see most of their lives
before you kick it
um unlike me [ __ ] super old dad here
now for some context before i jump into
the situation in middle school and high
school i
had been bullied by some kids saying i
was gay
i've always taken pride in how i dress
how i look my hair and i would
definitely describe myself
as metrosexual i was also very tall and
skinny growing up
and i had poor posture oh that's it
right there dude tall skinny poor
posture yeah you're going to get [ __ ]
with
it's the [ __ ] laws of the jungle
unfortunately anyway so the little [ __ ]
had a lot of ammunition and i honestly
don't blame them for it
but i'm not gay uh as you can imagine it
[ __ ] with me
and killed my confidence yeah dude
you're talking about someone who grew up
with orange hair
so yeah i know what it's like to have a
target on your back um in college i
decided i was going to put on some
muscle
really difficult i have the metabolism
of a hummingbird
but you got a great sense of humor
though so that makes up for a lot of it
and do something about one part of me
that i have always been self-conscious
about i gained 20 pounds and
am now proudly six to 170 pounds i do
well with the ladies
and i've had a few girlfriends over the
years uh
none as long as this one i have no
resentment for being bullied when i was
younger
in fact it served its purpose as
motivation for me to better
to be a better version of myself um
i think about bullying all the time i
think wish i could go back
and and stop a lot of it that i saw
um i was that weird i was like in the
middle of the pack
i got bullied i bullied people
you know get it off of me and put it on
to somebody else i really wish i had
matu you know you wish she had the
maturity now
of back then because some of the stuff i
think about i still think about some of
the [ __ ] that i saw some kids go through
it's just like [ __ ]
brutal um in the first year of dating my
girlfriend i opened up to her about
getting bullied and she told
and told her that's why the gym became
so important to me
she was supportive and felt bad that i
went through that when i was young
but she also wanted me to confirm with
her that i wasn't gay
her asking me frustrated me yeah that's
[ __ ] weird
but it was easy and i chalked it up to
her not knowing me well enough yet i was
pretty adamant about my answer and
thought she got the point
in our second year of dating she somehow
brings it up again and says are you sure
you aren't gay
like you aren't going to marry me have a
family and then come out right
whoa and this time around the question
pissed me off
we had this conversation really i've
been with you for two years we [ __ ]
weekly and it's great i'm also getting
insulted
no offense at all towards gay people but
my girlfriend is asking these questions
based on certain stereotypes
and i don't think there are enough
evidence air quote evidence for her to
be suspicious
i probably overreacted a bit no you
didn't but i hit a nerve
that my own girlfriend is bringing up
feelings i had when i was bullied in
middle school
uh got to be the end of it right well
we're three and a half years in and
tonight she pops the question yet again
dude break up with this chick
she words it similarly to how she worded
it the second time and i got pretty
heated i basically said
we've had this conversation now three
times i've told you each time that i'm
not gay
nor have i ever questioned it it pisses
me off that after
more than three years you're still
asking me this question this is not
normal i don't think
most women in relationship ask their man
yearly if they're secretly gay
and going to lead them so i'm insulted
she of course then becomes the victim
because i didn't react
how she wanted me to i said i'm sorry
but this
is not okay the next time you ask me
that question
i better have a dick in my mouth
am i wrong here no not at all
is dressing well being neat and keeping
myself well groomed really that much of
a red flag that my girlfriend should be
questioning my sexuality
i don't even talk like the stereotypical
gay dude
um any suggestions for how i can
get her to believe slash not ask me the
question anymore
can't wait to hear whatever you say go
[ __ ] yourself um yeah i would break up
with this chick
or i know this is what i would find out
what the [ __ ]
be like okay did your dad marry your mom
and then after you were born come out
and say he was gay like what is this
fear or
what the [ __ ] is it that i'm doing that
makes you keep asking me this question
uh that's what i would ask her and if
you don't like the answer i would
[ __ ] hit the road jack
and don't you come back no more that's
really [ __ ] up
now granted i haven't heard her [ __ ]
version of [ __ ]
um it's funny if she [ __ ] wrote in
um yeah i'd have to hear what her
concerns are to
have any [ __ ] idea but if you're
telling me the truth which how the hell
do i know but if you're telling me the
[ __ ] truth you're not gay
and you just dress well and [ __ ]
whatever and she's just
asking you that i mean you might be are
you an effeminate straight guy because
they have those too you you know
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know
i have no [ __ ] idea
so i do think that it is
[ __ ] up that you have expressed
i'll tell you know what else i think is
[ __ ] up that you've stayed with this
person
you're saying she's checked off all the
boxes i like how many boxes
is she checking off that once a year she
can ask you legitimately if you're gay
or not
and you still want to be with her
there's a lot of questions i have here
because i i think i mean
if i mean i i would just
one time maybe i think you can ask
somebody that once
and then a year later they do it again
it's like all right
i'm leaving you before i get like a
[ __ ] complex here
like jesus christ [ __ ] got me sitting
here watching john wayne movies now
trying to [ __ ] be extra
manly here so you stop asking me that
[ __ ] question
i don't know i have no idea but um
i don't think she's convinced and you're
three and a half years in you're 25 you
got your whole life ahead of you
um
i don't know this person but i can tell
you this reading your email
and just hearing your side of it this
woman is not checking off a lot of boxes
for me
personally um
so i don't know is it like her [ __ ]
weird way of trying
she doesn't want to break up with you so
she just keeps doing this thing that
annoys you i don't know
i i don't this that's a weird one
some [ __ ] heavy emails this [ __ ]
week jesus christ
i'd never kill myself but i'm [ __ ]
welcoming death whatever the hell that
was and then this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] some [ __ ] little stalin chick
running on h.o.a
jesus christ when the [ __ ] did this
podcast become so so so deep man
um all right that is the podcast
everybody um
so i'll leave you with this because what
that but what that guy was talking about
the guy eating too much
you know um
that really bothered me i know i hate
people being as much as a douche as i am
i don't like people being in pain
you know what i mean and uh someone
who's been in a lot of pain for a lot of
his life
and now figuring out that you know you
know your natural reaction
is too [ __ ] go away from pain
distract yourself from pain bury your
pain and all that and it's just
it just it's still gonna be there which
is why the next night you're still gonna
want to drink just as much if not more
or eat just as much
not as more uh go [ __ ] somebody you
shouldn't [ __ ] whatever your [ __ ]
addiction is
um so it's kind of amazing when you stop
just for a couple of months and really
try to work on whatever that [ __ ]
thing is that's bothering you
how much progress you can make um
quickly especially if you're talking to
somebody that understands what you're
going through so i wish that for all of
you
because if you don't deal with that pain
not only you're going to hurt yourself
you're going to hurt the people around
you that you love
all right that's the only public service
announcement i've ever made in this
podcast so
with that go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll
check in on you on
thursday